there is definitely a myth that
calcium is the main mineral that you
need for osteoporosis to strengthen your
bones and unfortunately so many
menopausal women are just Downing like
over a thousand milligrams of calcium of
course it's in the wrong form it's in an
elemental form called calcium carbonate
which is basically Limestone you'd be
better off chewing on the cement out
there but the point is that somehow we
have in our minds that if we take this
calcium
will prevent osteoporosis and it's
absolutely not true did you realize that
the majority of bone okay what makes it
bone I'm talking about over 70 percent
of it
is not calcium it is collagen which is
protein and there is calcium in bone for
sure there there's a good amount
but that calcium is tied up with
phosphorus but you don't hear people
saying well you need to have more
phosphorus for bone health and they
don't definitely say you need more
collagen for bone health it's mainly
calcium in some pretty hardcore research
and studies I'm going to put the links
down below people that take calcium do
not prevent fractures there is strong
evidence that if you take calcium in
supplement forms this can increase your
risk of cardiovascular accidents so if
calcium is not the main mineral that
builds bone to prevent osteoporosis what
is well it's a combination of many
things since bone is made out of protein
and that protein is activated by various
minerals and trace minerals like Cobalt
manganese magnesium and phosphorus and
many other minerals making sure you have
all of the trace minerals in the diet is
going help you you also need vitamins
vitamins help transport these minerals
and the most important vitamin for bone
health is vitamin d and vitamin K2 they
both work together by making calcium
available to make bone as well as to
help deliver the calcium that's in the
blood from the absorption of the
intestine
directly to the Bone that's vitamin K2
so you need Vitamin D3 and K2 to build
bone other factors relate to hormones if
you're deficient in like estrogen for
example that can lead to osteoporosis or
if you have too much cortisol really to
build bone you just need to focus on
creating a healthy body because it's not
just one thing it's the whole package
people that have bone loss
have an underlying metabolic problem
that is does not just focus on one loss
of one mineral it's not that you're just
losing calcium and that's why you have
osteoporosis that is just a total myth
now the question is since we're talking
about calcium what would be the best
source of calcium to support one part of
this puzzle to strengthen your bone
should you do more plant-based should
you do more Dairy the bioavailability of
calcium in Dairy is definitely better
than plants one reason is because
some plants like spinach for example and
swiss chard has a very potent inhibitor
of calcium called oxalates and so
oxalates block the absorption of calcium
beans are high in oxalates almonds are
high in oxalates eggplant and beets did
I mention beets are high in oxalates so
a combination of plants and dairy I
think would be good to help support
calcium but as far as dairy goes
raw milk cheese is a good source of
bioavailable calcium now it's more
difficult to find raw milk cheese in the
U.S if I'm correct I think you have to
buy this cheese that's over 60 days and
it and there's certain other regulations
but in Europe you can find raw cheese
all over the place but this raw cheese
supports the calcium complex it supports
the collagen protein and other minerals
and probiotics as well and since we're
on the topic of calcium
what are some of the problems when you
become deficient in calcium
um well I'm gonna go through them but I
do want to mention if you get your
calcium tested in the blood your serum
calcium that doesn't necessarily tell
you about the free available calcium
serum calcium could
make be made up of the protein-bound
calcium that's unavailable and not the
ionized calcium that is active in your
body so if you really want to know
if you have enough calcium that's
available you want to get a test that
measures the ionized calcium that will
give you a lot more information so if
you're deficient in calcium you can end
up with muscle spasms you can end up
with tetany which is a little twitching
sometimes it's on top of the left eyelid
right here the arm it could be anywhere
in the body and by the way tetany can
also be caused from a lack of magnesium
from a lack of potassium
because your body is too alkaline and
one cause of alkalinity is low potassium
and another cause is hyperventilation
that can change your pH and so if you
can imagine if someone has these panic
attacks and they're hyperventilating
and sometimes they get these little
Twitches well that's why your heart rate
can go up or down if you're deficient in
calcium another deficiency of low
calcium is numbness around your mouth
or numbness and tingling pins and
needles in your fingertips as well as in
your feet you can also have a spasm in
your larynx okay that comes from low
calcium that's going to show up in my
coarseness or kind of a rough
um sounding vocal cords or it can even
feel like you have this lump in the
throat calcium is also needed for many
different things too it's it's a good
thing just not needed in large amounts I
recommend to get it from the food mostly
but if you get it from a supplement make
sure it's on the lower amounts because
of that darn
problem or potential risk of increasing
your risk of getting heart attacks and
I'm not sure if that has only to do with
the type of calcium people take like
calcium carbonate but calcium actually
does provide some good benefits to
prevent against intestinal cancers as
well when you're low in calcium okay
there's a message sent to a gland that
surrounds your thyroid it's called the
parathyroid and you have four little
glands around this this thyroid and low
calcium activates the parathyroid to
increase
vitamin D okay to thereby increase more
calcium absorption in the intestine as
well as giving other signals to the Bone
to release calcium so we can actually
use calcium from the bone the bone is
kind of a reservoir of calcium and one
point to mention about vitamin D if
you're deficient vitamin D which most
people are you're going to have a hard
time raising the calcium up to the level
it needs to be from the intestine to the
blood so if you have vitamin D you can
increase this calcium by a factor of 20x
okay but if you don't have that vitamin
D you're going to have a problem with
calcium another thing that's needed with
this absorption of calcium is magnesium
which is another factor a lot of people
are deficient in magnesium so if you
don't have enough magnesium you're not
going to be able to have the levels of
calcium that you need
other factors are involved in calcium as
well for example if you consume
an excessive amount of protein that can
create some loss of calcium but again if
you're taking enough calcium in it's not
anything to be worried about but I just
want to point it out that there are
things that tend to cause a loss of
calcium and that would be excessive
amount of protein that would be
excessive amount of sodium okay and I'm
not telling you to cut down your sodium
I'm just kind of giving you the
relationship between these two minerals
another thing is if you drink a lot of
coffee or caffeine in excess amounts can
deplete your calcium also if you are
exposed to a lot of phosphorus you can
lose calcium from the bone now where do
you get phosphorus from well it's
actually in animal Meats but it's also
in soft drinks it's people that are
drinking all these sodas all day long
boy they're just depleting the calcium
left and right also if you have refined
sugar that can also deplete your calcium
levels anyway I wanted to bring up your
awareness on this relationship between
calcium and your bones and make sure you
had all the information and this is
another reason why you should just eat
healthy to create strong bones since
we're on this topic of calcium and I did
mention this thing called oxalates you
should definitely check out my video and
oxalates if you haven't already seen it
and I'll put it up right here